santos tiene 48 años y es de brasil
lleva 5 años en españa sin documentación
oficial
intento luchar contra la burocracia por
sí solo pero finalmente acudió a una
abogada trabajando buena salen buenas
noticias podría conseguir un permiso de
trabajo pronto siempre hay gente que
quiere pagarle la mitad o mucho menos de
la mitad por el mismo trabajo que haría
una persona que está regularizada con
estás nervioso mirando para los lados
pues si puede pasar a alguien aunque te
piden documentación desde ahora puedo
dormir tranquilo pero mucho mejor la
última reforma migratoria del gobierno
ha simplificado los trámites para que
los migrantes indocumentados que llevan
dos años en españa' consigan sus papeles
con la opción de la residencia de
arraigo por formación va a poder ayudar
a muchos extranjeros que se encuentran
actualmente situación irregular ya que
les está dando la oportunidad de tener
una residencia sin necesidad de tener
una oferta de trabajo otro grupo que se
beneficie de la reforma son los
estudiantes desde ahora cuando finalicen
sus estudios recibirán automáticamente
un año extra de visado en españa un
tiempo vital para conseguir un trabajo
con tanta burocracia y tanta demora en
resolver lo de los papeles da la
sensación de que las únicas opciones que
tiene es devolverte a tu país o trabajar
de forma ilegal ante la escasez de
trabajadores y una población cada vez
más envejecida españa ha tenido que
transformar su enfoque migratorio un
paso histórico según la fundación por
causa no solo regulariza a las personas
que ya están aquí sino que ofrece
posibilidades de regularización a
aquellas personas que vayan a venir por
lo tanto lo que hace es regularizar todo
el sistema y eso es era necesario y es
importantísimo y es una novedad
prácticamente en europa
actualmente se estima que medio millón
de extranjeros viven en españa sin
papeles